hey mater wanna race uh well come on
look at you all charged up the race but
i don't have a chance again no
come
[Applause]
just letting you know i'm gonna be gone
cause i'm heading back east to go to my
sister's wedding wait a minute you have
a sister whoa goggles of mine man must
be ages since you've seen her what if i
go with you really let's make it a road
trip
there's thousands of things to see
but just the tiniest little taste of
death
oh dear mother
i'm guessing this is the beginning of
something great you got that right
we wander the backroads this is so cool
make new friends
where are you guys headed
i gotta rinse off this old baggage
whoa
look at you
what about
me can't mess with perfection
i spy with my little eye
two quackity kitty cars
points for pageantry
[Music]
this is not what i expected
all the bumps along the road
that's what makes life worth living
[Applause]
i love these i don't know come on look
you picked the last stop world's largest
tire maze mcqueen mater mcqueen mater
mcqueen